[Music]
hello good morning everyone it's seven
o'clock it looks like the game is over
for the tennis star novak djokovic the
world number one has flown into a storm
in australia over his covert vaccine
exemption we'll have the latest as he
faces deportation
back here as travel restrictions are
eased we'll speak to the transport
secretary grant chaps about the
government's strategy for tackling the
spread of omicron
also ahead
pay attention and focus we'll speak to
the best-selling author johann harry on
his battle to get kids
to look up from their phones
plus keep on walking the great-grandad
with a quadruple heart bypass he's going
to walk 10 miles a day every day this
year
it's thursday the 6th of january
facing deportation the world number
tennis one novak djokovic has his visa
to enter australia cancelled after an
outcry over his covert vaccine exemption
rules
are rules
and there are no special cases
with nearly a million waiting for
treatment mps warn plans to tackle the
nhs backlog could be derailed by a lack
of staff
we're really calling upon the government
and the secretary of state is to not
keep burying their heads in the sand
there is a massive problem and it needs
sorting
i'm live at the great western hospital
in swindon where high demand for kobe
beds and staff shortages are causing
increasing demand
maxwell's lawyer demands a re-trial
after one of the jurors who convicted
her reveals he was the victim of sexual
abuse
remaining defiant one year on from the
capitol riots in washington donald
trump's team maintained the u.s election
was rigged
former president trump is still
absolutely of the belief
that he won the election in 2020. yeah
absolutely
and the weather after a frosty start for
many strong winds rain and hill snow
will spread eastwards
[Music]
hello good morning the world number one
tennis player novak djokovic is facing
deportation from australia he was
refused entry by border officials in
melbourne because he didn't meet the
country's covert vaccine requirements it
means his hopes of defending his
australian open title appear to be over
sky's shaman freeman powell reports
it's not the way the tennis world number
one had expected to enter australia to
defend his open title
rushed into a quarantine hotel in a van
surrounded by guards in protective
clothing
instead of being fully vaccinated novak
djokovic had secured a medical exemption
before leaving europe
but he was blocked by australia's border
force who said his visa didn't tally
with that medical exemption his coach
goran ivan nisovich was allowed through
but was stuck at the airport waiting and
writing
not the most usual trip down under
australia's prime minister went in front
of the cameras to confirm djokovic's
visa had been cancelled and he'd be
getting no special treatment
rules
are rules
and there are no special cases it is not
appropriate for me to go into mr
jockovich's own medical history that
would not be a fair thing for us to do
that is a day of matters for him to
discuss in terms of his own medical
history
but what i all i can say is that the
evidence for medical exemption that was
provided was found to be insufficient
almost all of the players and staff at
the australian open have been vaccinated
some have also been given exemptions
but the djokovic case has infuriated
people in the world's most locked down
city all of a sudden he's he's been
exempt and can play and i think it's an
absolute disgrace and i won't be
watching it
even the djokovic fans gathered outside
melbourne airport
say they think pulling out is the only
option well
obviously
we are disappointed but that's something
we can't really change
we have no influence
serbia's president has even waded in he
spoke to the world number one on the
phone and hit out at his treatment on
instagram promising to step in
i told novak that the whole of serbia is
with him and that our bodies are doing
everything to see that the harassment of
the world's best tennis player is
brought to an end immediately
in line with all norms of international
law serbia will fight for novak truth
and justice
djokovic has launched an appeal it's
been heard today but as it stands his
route into australia is blocked and his
stance on vaccination leaves him in this
quarantine hotel instead of defending
his title
shimon freeman powell sky news
for joining me live from adelaide is sky
news australia's joel phillip and joel
uh ushman was saying that appeal we're
due to hear a result of it quite soon
aren't we
well it appears that it has just begun
again in the federal circuit court in
melbourne it was adjourned earlier today
but indeed for the for the application
process to go through but it has just
begun once again it is not clear at this
stage if we'll get an outcome tonight or
if djokovic will be staying for the
coming days here
in melbourne what's been heard so far in
the court is a discussion about whether
he can get access to a tennis court
while the situation is unfolding and
tennis australia has requested that they
find out if he can play by no later than
tuesday next week the judge responded to
that by saying the tale won't be wagging
the dog here now his lawyers are
mounting a challenge on the denial of
his visa to australia saying that it was
unfair and unreasonable among other
things now in this situation you
mentioned the medical exemption what
it's being reported here has occurred is
that djokovic has attempted to claim
that he is naturally immune and entered
the country via that
precipice or situation but and although
it's used in other parts of the world as
a relevant form of exemption it is not
used here in australia the australian
government has confirmed that today and
it's also being reported that they wrote
to tennis australia on various occasions
letting them know that that's the case
so how it got to this situation and that
the health experts and the immigration
department that tennis australia and of
course the world's number one superstar
novak himself didn't communicate to each
other is not clear at the moment we'll
see what unfolds in the coming days
we will indeed joel thanks very much for
that
now pre-departure cover testing has been
removed for eligible fully vaccinated
people leaving the uk
this along with other changes to test
for travellers will make it easier and
cheaper for travel to and from the uk
from tomorrow well the transport
secretary grant chats joins me now um mr
shaps we're told that the omicron is
everywhere yet all of a sudden we're
seeing a lot of these rules being
removed are we not letting down our
defenses a little bit too early
no definitely not uh this was always
brought in on a temporary basis and it
did its job um we since bringing in the
the red list and then these additional
tests managed to get 13 million extra
jabs the booster jab in people's arms so
it served a purpose obviously omicron is
global it's worldwide everybody has it
now the proportion that comes in from
overseas is completely uh is minuscule
by comparison with the numbers uh that
are actually here so um it's now
widespread and uh in a sense omicron
testing has outlived its usefulness so
we're able to withdraw it from uh
international uh travel uh today
and carry on sorry
but that's omicron what about other
variants
by doing this we are potentially adding
loads of other variants in without
testing people before they come to the
uk
well because it's global
we're just as likely to perhaps have a
variant here we saw that last year um
with the year before now with the kent
variant also called alpha
so of course a variant can can occur
anywhere this country does do more
genomic sequencing that's when you find
out that what the variant might be than
any other country in the world so we're
still carrying on that massive
sequencing program we'll carry on doing
that because if you get a positive
lateral flow test after you've traveled
and that is the one test that remains
you must take a lateral flow test by day
two
and if you do get a positive then that
needs to be
pcr'd on the nhs and sequenced so we've
still got that protection in place but
we think this is proportionate uh a lot
of jobs depend on travel a lot of jobs
depend on tourism and we need to keep
these uh measures in line
with actually what's going on with
omicron around the world which is is
everywhere now it's the predominant uh
strain of coronavirus
not everyone's convinced how the welsh
government health minister said that she
was making the changes reluctantly and a
stress that the welsh government was
still advising against all but essential
international travel why do you think
they're not concerned
yeah look it's always been for the
different devolved administrations
around the uk to decide as far as i'm
aware actually the whole of the uk is
going to be moving on this together so
these rules will apply
um everywhere and these are judgment
calls it's absolutely uh right to say
but but but i do have to say the idea
that somehow the united kingdom is is
safe and secure but if you travel
outside of our borders uh then you know
somehow it will be you know it's a
dangerous world out there um i think
sort of lies the truth which is that
omicron is everywhere around the world
we've got very significant testing in
place and i i don't think any country
does more testing
than we do per head of population so for
example on tuesday this week
i saw there were over 2 million
coronavirus tests which took place
and so we you know we keep a very very
close eye on these things but you know
uh people still need to be able to get
around and see uh family perhaps
elsewhere in the road in the world
business needs to be done elsewhere and
as i say
many we we have pretty high levels of
coronavirus um here so it's not like if
you go abroad you're necessarily going
somewhere with higher levels you may
well be somewhere with lower levels so
we just didn't see the reason to keep
what were always temporary measures in
place for a moment longer
than was useful and in a sense they just
outlived their usefulness when it comes
to international travel
do we have a shortage of tests
no we don't uh when we've another
spokesman yesterday said that changes
were to make the best use of our testing
system at a time of high prevalence
slightly suggests that uh there's a
certain amount of of prioritizing yeah
no that was specifically in reference to
uh not requiring to do a pcr test if
you're asymptomatic and you take a
lateral flow you no longer need to
confirm that with a
pcr test so that was in reference
something slightly different and yes it
is true to say that we want to make sure
that we're focusing those tests on
critical workers on the front line
as
for example with transport workers or
with health workers to make sure they're
available so we don't want to over test
for no reason but remember the travel
tests were always provided by the
private sector and that single lateral
flow that's still required will still be
a private sector uh test um but we've
got a huge amount of testing um
available as i mentioned we tested two
million in a single day on tuesday
and and there are tests available for
people who need to get pcr tests uh
lateral flow supply uh is is very much
available sometimes delivery of those
tests is proving uh challenging and
we're increasing the number of delivery
routes available through the royal mail
and elsewhere as well
could you just clarify the rules on
testing for us and the advice seems to
be that if you have one of the three
main symptoms um that you should get a
pcr otherwise not now this is confusing
quite a lot of people because a lot of
people with omicron have aches and pains
and not necessarily a temperature and a
cough should they just do a lateral flow
test
yeah that's right so um just to clarify
this if you have one of the main
symptoms that they're listed on the nhs
website um then by all means book a a
pcr test
for other people who are perhaps going
about their normal lives but maybe feel
they'll be in a position where they'll
meet vulnerable people
that's where the lateral flow tests are
available i know a lot of people over
christmas myself included taking lateral
flow tests before going to see my
elderly parents and that's good practice
and it helps to protect everyone in fact
in my family
my my eldest son took a test had
absolutely no symptoms whatsoever and
found he was positive and then had to go
and self-isolate for
for nine days until he got uh two days
of negative uh lateral flow tests so
that's the purpose of lateral flow tests
particularly good where people are
asymptomatic and it can find people who
have got cases but pcr tests where you
are symptomatic that's that's the
message
it seems to me that the current message
from the government generally seems to
be that we are just going to have to
live with covert as you were saying you
know
it's not a case that there's a big bad
world out there we have a lot of it in
the country um
but there's a a lot of of messages
coming from the nhs from staff and we
have this report out today about
pressure on the nhs
and they feel that actually living with
it
is just not possible that we are
reaching a crisis point in the in the
nhs what do you say to that
well we've always known in dealing with
omnichrome and this is where our plan b
has been in place that we are uh
if you like always trying to find the
right compromise between going too tight
on restrictions lockdowns and let's face
it they have a lot of costs uh connected
and monetary costs obviously to the
economy but also to people's jobs also
for people's mental health
of these lockdowns
and then again not wanting uh our
hospitals to be overrun and uh this is
where i think the plan b has been shown
to be the right approach so far uh we we
know that uh that
there are hospitals with critical
warnings at the moment that that doesn't
seem to be like it's going swimmingly
for them
yeah so uh there are 137 uh trusts there
are 24 which are uh critical uh it's not
entirely unusual for hospitals to go
critical over the winter often with
things like the flu pandemic but there
are very real pressures which i
absolutely
recognize and we know what it's like
when these hospitals are under pressure
my dad was in hospital this time last
year when there were 40 000 people in
hospital with coronavirus and the
pressures are very real this year we've
got five thousand
more doctors uh 10 000 more nurses in
place
and it's very important that we do
provide all those resources and we've
we've we've provided an extra 5.9
billion pounds to hospitals a 36 billion
pound catch-up program uh as well
but i do absolutely recognize those
pressures as i say what we want to do is
steer the country through
the omrichrom uh wave and i think so far
plan b is shown to have been the right
way forward not shutting down the whole
country yet again with all the costs of
people's mental health
and elsewhere uh but making sure that
we're providing the extra resources uh
to hospitals uh unfortunately in terms
of those extra resources
in terms of those extra resources i
report out from mps today uh saying that
nhs waiting lists which are already huge
or to double by 2025
huge numbers uh in the northeast
especially
what is your solution to that
yeah i mentioned the amount of money
that we're putting into tackling those
waiting lists so we've got a 5.9 billion
catch up the 36 million that i that i
mentioned um it's one of the reasons why
we took what most people would accept
was a difficult decision but nonetheless
i think worthwhile one uh last year
which is to say that we will
be having that national insurance rise
in order to pay uh in part for catch up
on the number of operations and routine
procedures which because we've now been
tackling coronavirus for what is it
nearly two years uh have by necessity in
some cases not been able to to take
place we want to make sure that we catch
up with that we're putting record sums
into
our nhs we love the nhs we want it to be
able to function i think most people
watching a program accept that of course
these have been exceptional times we've
never faced anything
like a virus like this before in modern
history
yeah and in terms of support in the
cabinet jacob rees-mogg not quite as in
favor
of the national insurance rise uh as
others we understand from yesterday's
cabinet meeting how did did his
suggestion that that should be scrapped
the rise go down
well i do cabinets take place in in in
private was i'm not going to get into
commenting on a cabinet meeting uh
content we have a plan uh it is to catch
up on uh on things like the backlog in
uh in nhs uh care which has come about
uh unfortunately through coronavirus and
that plan is being put into into place
uh you know it is also true to say that
we want to make sure that we uh relieve
tax pressures uh on public uh as and
when we can but you know that has to be
done in line government could change
their mind on this and scrap it
oh well look we're absolutely committed
to doing two things one catching up with
the backlog in the nhs and that's why we
have this national insurance uh increase
for specifically for that purpose and
two sourcing out the long-term issue of
social care where people lose their
homes if they have specific types of
illnesses for example dementia uh which
has always seemed to me to be cruel and
unfair particularly when uh you're you
know helped by the nhs if you had
something else and that was eventually
uh the thing which you passed away from
so uh no we're absolutely committed to
making those changes it's an historic
change that i think will bring a lot of
security to families up and down the the
country so we'll certainly be doing that
okay grant chaps good to talk to you
today thank you for joining us thanks
very much
well as we just mentioned mps are
warning that plans to tackle the record
waiting list for nhs treatment could be
derailed by emergency care and a lack of
staff a backlog of nearly six million
people in england either bennett reports
three patients with different needs in
different parts of the country all
facing the same unbearable weight for
treatment
this isn't living this is existing at
the moment
um and
um it's just hideous it is affecting
literally every single part
of my life
i feel as though i've been forgotten
perhaps they hope that my age will seek
me off before anything else happens you
learn to put a bit of a brave face on it
if you like but that fear is always
there in the background
there are nearly six million people
waiting for planned treatment and there
are fears this could double over the
next three years of those already on the
list three hundred thousand have been
waiting for more than a year and twelve
thousand more than two years
now mps are warning that government
plans to tackle the backlog could be
derailed by record demands on emergency
care and a lack of staff there are
nearly a hundred thousand vacancies for
nhs positions
all we hear is about
the concerns we have but there's no
action plan we're really calling upon
the government and the secretary of
state is to not keep burying their heads
in the sand there is a massive problem
and it needs sourcing
some hospitals like this one in north
london have found ways to limit the
backlog this is one of seven in the
local area that have pooled resources so
that patients can be treated more
quickly if they're willing to travel but
it's only ever going to be a quick fix a
long-term solution is desperately needed
the government says it's provided nearly
six billion pounds to tackle the backlog
and pledged more in the future but
experts say money isn't the problem
the fact that's going to limit the rate
at how quickly that money translates
into better services for patients is
staffing can you find enough staff
whether domestically or recruiting
internationally to make the best use of
that money so we can see the taxpayer
investment resulting in shorter weights
for care
a knock-on of kovid which like the virus
isn't going away the backlog will
undoubtedly get worse before it gets
better iva bennett sky news
well let's talk to dan whitehead he's at
the great western hospital in swindon
which has declared a critical incident
and what is the situation there dan
well this is well this is one of 20 nhs
trusts across england which have
declared these internal critical
incidents it did so on tuesday and to
our understanding this morning it is
still within what is its highest level
of internal alert system what it
essentially means is that they can call
on extra support
and extra resources and to look to
discharge extra patients from the
hospital they are under extreme pressure
pressure extremely busy is what the
hospital says inside now as of yesterday
morning
they had 72 coved patients inside the
hospital behind me three of those were
inside intensive care but the problem is
exacerbated because of the staff
shortages due to sickness due to covid19
so it is almost a perfect star a storm
of an increasing number of people coming
into the urgent care and emergency
departments here
a rising number of uh kovid 19 patients
and those at staff shortages now on the
website for the nhs trust they've urged
the families of patients inside the
hospital to do all they can to see if
they can help look after their patients
at home they talk about collecting their
loved ones loved ones promptly stocking
the medicine cabinet at home and
arranging their own transport to get
their loved ones back home it's all
about clearing the backlog of beds and
as we heard in iva's report just then
nearly six million people waiting for
treatments on nhs waiting lists and that
is why the uh
care health and care recovery plan is
being urged from
the committee to ensure the government
does more to try and clear this backlog
of what is already a very difficult time
for the nhs and hospitals right across
england dan thanks very much
well let's take a look at the latest
daily cover data for the uk and
194
747 new cases of coronavirus have been
reported 334 more deaths also although
this is a jump the number does take into
account those since the 1st of january
because of the lag in data reporting
over the bank holiday
that takes the number of those who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
to 149
284
well on the sky news daily podcast today
we look at the pressure rising omicron
cases and staff absences are putting on
the nhs you can find it from your
podcast supplier or by scanning the qr
code on your screen right now
still to come on the program the former
health secretary jeremy hunt will be
here to discuss the emergency care
crisis and growing waiting lists
we'll talk to the leader of the liberal
democrats sir ed davey who's calling for
a new tax on energy companies to help
families cope with rising gas prices
shadow secretary of state for work and
pensions jonathan ashworth joins me at
five plus eight as more nhs trusts
around the country declare critical
incidents
[Music]
well in other news today police in
kazakhstan's largest city almaty say
that tens of rioters have been in their
words eliminated
authorities and protesters clashed in
the city's main square where hundreds
have been protesting the rise in fuel
prices it comes as a russian-led
military alliance of ex-soviet states
has said it will send peacekeeping
forces into kazakhstan at the
president's request
this year's grammy awards in los angeles
have been postponed because of
coronavirus for the second year in a row
the recording academy and cbs said the
decision to press ahead with the 2022
ceremony simply contained too many risks
italy will introduce mandatory
vaccination for over 50s from next month
it's already been compulsory for
teachers and healthcare workers since
october but the tightening of rules was
announced on the day italy reported
record high covert infections
around 90 percent of over 50s in italy
have received two doses so far anyone
not vaccinated could be fined at least
600 euros
glenn maxwell's defense team are calling
for a retrial after one of the jurors
who convicted her revealed that he was a
victim of sexual abuse she was found
guilty last week of recruiting underage
girls to be sexually abused by geoffrey
epstein joe pike reports now from new
york
she is a convicted child sex trafficker
but for how long after a member of the
jury that found gilay maxwell guilty put
that very verdict in doubt
in a media interview juror scotty david
said he had been a victim of child
sexual abuse and that he discussed that
experience during jury deliberations
yet in a pre-trial questionnaire all
potential jurors were asked have you or
a friend or family member ever been a
victim of sexual harassment sexual abuse
or sexual assault
they could select yes they had
yes a friend or family member had
or no
being a victim of sexual abuse would not
have automatically excluded this man
from being a juror but it may have
affected the jury selection process he
says he flew through the questionnaire
doesn't remember that particular
question but would have answered it
honestly it's now up to the judge to
investigate exactly what happened work
out if this man has been truthful and
decide whether any of this affects the
fairness of gillane maxwell's trial
one former prosecutor argues retrials
are rarely granted
it's very common for defense attorneys
to use
the comments of jurors after there's a
verdict and then to go to court with
emotion and try to overturn the verdict
by citing the jurors comments it's
extremely common it is not extremely
common for
that type of motion by the defense to be
successful it just isn't because we know
that jurors
are human beings and that they bring to
the process
all kinds of life experiences
gelane maxwell's lawyers want a retrial
soon we'll find out in the coming weeks
if they'll get it and whether we'll see
12 new jurors in these seats joe pike
sky news new york
time to get a look at the weather now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's going to turn wet and windy from
the west today with snow on the hills
britain mostly dry and calm with an
extensive frost severe in places ireland
and northern ireland will see any frost
soon lifting as wind and rain spread
from the west
northern and western britain will turn
wet and windy this morning with coastal
gales there'll be snow on the hills and
low levels from the north in a time
elsewhere eastern england will stay fine
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up after the break the former
health secretary jeremy hunt will be
here to discuss the emergency care
crisis and growing waiting lists in the
nhs
[Music]
the transport secretary grant chaps has
defended the government's handling of
backlogs in the nhs mr shapz told me
earlier that it had to take difficult
spending decisions to ensure that the
nhs could cope
we're absolutely committed to doing two
things one catching up with the backlog
in the nhs and that's why we have this
national insurance
increase for specifically for that
purpose and two sourcing out the
long-term issue of social care where
people lose their homes if they have
specific types of illnesses for example
dementia
which has always seemed to me to be
cruel and unfair particularly when uh
you're you know helped by the nhs if you
had something else and that was
eventually uh the thing which you passed
away from so uh no we're absolutely
committed to making those changes it's
an historic change that i think will
bring a lot of security to families up
and down the the countries
well political correspondent tomorrow
conan is with me now and this is in
response to the health and social care
committee who are
putting out a report today showing up
the extent of the backlog within the nhs
yes absolutely it's nearly six million
already and
covid the omicron wave has just made it
worse because the nhs is trying to get
through all those procedures that were
delayed in the last wave and then you've
got all this increased pressure on
hospitals from covered patients and
increasingly from staff being off which
means that hospitals are in such a
difficult spot nonetheless no political
appetite is pretty clear for more
restrictions so they're going to have to
try and ride that out as best they can
now an interesting little row is
developing in government now because you
remember back in september boris johnson
announced that there was going to be a
rise in national insurance in order to
to help solve the social care crisis but
also to help the nhs recover and cut the
backlog now that's coming in on the
first of april it's a pretty steep one
it's going to cost someone on the
average uh salary 250 pounds a year and
i think we're now seeing tory mps very
concerned along with rising energy bills
and rising inflation people are really
going to be feeling the squeeze this
year we're understanding cabinet
yesterday when they discussed covid um
jacob rees-mogg said look why don't we
not raise this national insurance tax
now i don't think that's going to happen
and grant shap's made a pretty staunch
defense of why it's needed this is what
he said
oh we haven't got that grab book but
essentially he wouldn't comment on on on
what was said in cabinet he's actually
private but he he made it really clear
didn't he that the government is is
committed to this so sort of knock down
any suggestion and i think i then asked
him you know is the government he said
it's crucial to cl if we want to clear
the backlog it's crucial to get this
extra money in but i think we're already
seeing you saw yesterday with boris
johnson in parliament every conservative
and labour mp asking him about cost of
living issues i think there's going to
be real pressure to find something to
ease that strain okay tomorrow thanks
very much
well let's get more on this we're joined
now by the former health secretary and
the chair of the commons health and
social care committee jeremy hunt uh and
a new uh of course chairing this
committee which has released this report
today about the backlog uh it's it's
pretty desperate stuff isn't it a pretty
damning report massive backlog of
operations
the report describes it as an
unquantifiable challenge the number of
children admitted to the children at an
adolescent mental health health service
up 94
people feeling abandoned by the nhs
where do you start what's your greatest
area of concern
well we do give the government credit
for the fact that it's perhaps of the
most difficult problem of all which is
what tomorrow was alluding to just then
which is finding the money to address
these problems the
12 billion pound rise in national
insurance funded through the new health
and social care levy will make a a
massive difference but the result of
that is that people aren't worrying now
across the nhs about money what they're
worrying about is workforce they're
finding incredibly difficult to get the
doctors nurses
care workers the crucial people to
deliver this extra care
just aren't there the health foundations
say that it will take about 4 000 more
doctors
and 17 000 more nurses to deal with the
backlog and we haven't had a plan from
the government as to where those doctors
and nurses are going to come from and
that is the biggest single gap at the
moment so i
did you actually just say that that
people in the nhs aren't worried about
money because i i just sort of think
that beggars belief i mean
it is all about money isn't it it's not
about the number of staff you have it's
about the money to pay for those stuff
if you haven't got the money to pay for
the staff you can't have the staff
they're not going to work for free
well curiously you know in many periods
in the nhs history there have been big
debates about money but but right now
particularly after this 12 billion pound
rise
people of course welcome additional
funding but the funding is there what
they're saying is what hospitals are
saying is we have the funding we just
can't recruit the doctors and nurses
with that funding because we can't find
them and what we need is a plan and so
one of the things we say is that we're
concerned that we're not training enough
doctors and nurses for the future
we recommend the government has an
independent study every few years as to
how many doctors and nurses we should be
training
they've rejected that we hope they'll
change their mind on that because we
really do need to give people confidence
that we're training enough doctors and
nurses for the future and they don't
have that confidence at the moment
i mean the fact that we don't know how
many doctors and nurses and care staff
are being trained seems astonishing i
mean clearly coverts have an impact but
but a lot of these problems
are are long-term problems within the
nhs that there'll be some people say
that this is a bit rich coming from a
health secretary a former health a man
who was was health secretary for six
years out of the last 12 years of the
conservative government i mean
a lot of these problems are problems
that you should have solved and a lot of
these problems are legacy problems from
your time when you were in charge
well i'm sure i could have done some
things better but in this particular
area i did make a lot of progress i set
up five new medical schools i increased
the number of doctors and nurses we
trained by 25
but what i'm saying is we are going to
continually need to refine the numbers
that we train the number of new
specialties that we
develop new skills for as new
technologies new treatments new
medicines come on stream
and we need to solve this problem once
and for all and that's why this report
is saying
let's have an independent study every
two years where someone
looks carefully at the number of doctors
that we're going to need in 10 15 20
years time and really make sure we're
training them and that's what that's
what we're recommending this morning
we're also saying
that you can't just have a strategy
based on the six million people on the
waiting list because if emergency care
falls over
the whole nhs falls over we saw this
week how 17 hospitals in the northwest
have cancelled all their elective care
because of problems in their emergency
care and issues with omicron so you have
to have an encompassing solution that
looks at social care mental health
primary emergency care as well as those
long waiting lists but is is the
solution to the issues facing the nhs at
the moment let's count how many doctors
and nurses there are going to be every
two years i
you know i think a lot of people would
just see
essentially what we're hearing from from
various people one union saying we're
heading for a perfect storm your report
itself says that there are nhs staff who
say no amount of money will make them
stay in the nhs
it seems to me from this report that the
nhs is entirely broken
and that the the party that you belong
to have been in part in government for
12 years and have to take the
responsibility for that
well i think
the nhs has improved in many ways but
we've just come through the biggest
challenge in its history which is a
pandemic
which
was incredibly difficult for everyone in
the nhs they did an absolutely fantastic
job and we look at the nhs
through that lens and we're saying look
this has been really hard what do we
need to do now to help the nhs get
through this and set it up for the
future and um i think if you talk to
people on the front line
they will say that there are workforce
shortages in every area it's the biggest
thing on most people's minds
and they understand that the government
hasn't got a silver bullet you can't
suddenly magic up lots more doctors and
nurses it takes
seven years to train a doctor ten years
to train a gp
and three years to train a nurse so
these things can't be solved overnight
but they would like to know that there's
a long term plan in place and that it's
not always going to be like this and
over a period of time those workforce
shortages will ease and that's what we
are recommending in this report would
make a big difference uh both to the
morale of people on the front line and
to the practical ability of the nhs to
deliver the excellent service that we
all want
jeremy hunt thank you very much
thank you
new research suggests air pollution in
urban areas across the world contributed
to 1.8 million excess deaths in 2019.
nearly 2 million cases of asthma and
children were blamed on nitrogen dioxide
in the air in the same year aisha zaheed
reports
ella was only 9 years old when she died
following a severe asthma attack
in the last few years of her life she'd
been admitted to hospital 27 times and
suffered multiple seizures
in a landmark ruling in 2020
a coroner said excessive air pollution
contributed to her death
we will never know really when
ella's problems really started the only
thing i can say to you was three months
before her seventh birthday that's when
we first noticed him she was born um
right right next to the south circler
and obviously that's where her final
breath was taken so for all of ella's
life she was breathing illegal air
air pollution led to 1.8 million excess
deaths in cities across the globe in
2019 according to new research in the
same year nearly 2 million asthma cases
among children worldwide were attributed
to nitrogen dioxide pollution and
modeling suggests 2.5 billion people are
living in urban areas with high levels
of air pollution
experts say the effects of this could be
catastrophic
the reason those uh air pollution is has
such a huge impact on our health is that
it really attacks almost every organ of
our body
it comes in uh deep into our lungs in
some cases for the very fine particles
an ultrafine particle into the
bloodstream and it affects pretty much
anything from our brain and it affects
how particularly how children's
cognitive development
uh and lung development
is impaired so we need to push that that
that tendency so that uh we really
transform our city so that it's so easy
to walk by take public transportation
everywhere we have to do it
while the uk has seen reductions in air
pollution over the last decade the
government acknowledges there's still
more to do
it says it's committed to setting
stretching and ambitious targets
[Music]
ella's mum rosamund is campaigning for
change to come sooner rather than later
she hopes saving lives will be her
i
daughter's
legacy
to sky news
and remind you can catch the daily
climate show here on sky news every
weekday at the new time of 8 30 in the
evening
now a year on from the storming of the
capital in washington d.c the former
president donald trump is shrugging off
attempts to hold him responsible and
seems set on positioning himself as the
commanding force behind the republican
party here's our u.s correspondent mark
stone
washington dc january 2022 a picture
postcard image but is it one which
belies a troubling and divided reality
it's a year since the event now known
simply as january 6th
a coup attempt an insurrection an effort
certainly by supporters of donald trump
to change the result of the election
[Applause]
as politicians hidden police were
overrun five people died and a nation
was shaken
about 12 months on team trump is as
active as ever and as defiant as ever
liz harrington is donald trump's
spokesperson and as president trump
likes to say the real insurrection was
the subversion of the american people's
will on november 3rd
that was
the
the theft
what january 6 was was the protest he
said we will fight we will fight like
hell and if you don't fight like hell
you're not gonna have a country anymore
that was incitement wasn't it no that's
nothing compared to what people on the
left say and you know he's speaking
metaphorically
[Applause]
but it has now emerged that as all this
was unfolding some of those closest to
mr trump including his own son were
urging the president to intervene it has
gone too far don jr said in a text
message
over the past year despite being banned
from social media donald trump has
remained in constant campaign mode and
he has continued to claim against all
facts but to audiences who believe him
that the election was stolen you are
saying that that former president trump
is still absolutely of the belief
that he won the election in 2020. yeah
absolutely and you look at it even
though even though 64 out of 65
challenges in courts around this nation
when there have been recounts and
recounts
they've checked very clearly
and those
have been proven to be very fair
elections or fair counts
no matter how many times you count the
same
stuffed ballot box
it's still going to be a stuffed ballot
box
yet audits too proved no wrong doing and
the dominant view among historians
academics those who would be dismissed
as the establishment is that democracy
itself in america is in a perilous state
republicans up and down the country have
arrived at a point where they look at
january 6 as a blueprint as a dress
rehearsal as a trial run for the next
presidential election and they are at
the state level trying to get themselves
in a position where at the next uh
presidential election they will be able
to execute that blueprint more
effectively as a way to hold on to power
donald trump has not said whether he
will run again but a year since january
the sixth he has successfully positioned
himself as the commanding force behind
the republican party mark stone sky news
in washington d.c
[Music]
the liberal democrats are calling for
attacks on the profits of oil and gas
firms to help people facing soaring
energy costs the leader of the liberal
democrats and former energy secretary
sir ed davey uh joins me now uh good to
talk to you today um just explain what
is this uh you're dubbing it the robin
hood tax what is it how would it work
we're really worried by the rising
energy bills that people are facing
rising gas prices means that people's
heating bills will go up by at least 50
percent average energy bills rising by
at least 700 pounds next year so we need
help for people but that has to be paid
for
and alongside these the gas prices
hitting people's heating bills they're
also increasing profits of the oil and
gas sector massively the bp's chief
executive said his company was a cash
machine so i think it's reasonable to do
what's happened in the past and have a
robin hood tax to tax some of that
profits so we can afford to pay the real
help for vulnerable people and people on
low incomes
but what message does this send to the
rest of the world and to businesses who
who want to come and do business here in
the uk that at any point the uk
government might turn around and say
actually we're going to do this massive
tax hike on you right now
well this has been done by governments
of all persuasions in the uk in the past
the spanish have just done a winful tax
so this is not unusual let's remember
these profits were totally unexpected
they're absolutely massive and it's
simply unfair liberal democrats think
that these large oil and gas companies
need some small and medium-sized ones
some of the traders are making massive
profits while people who are on low
incomes may go hungry and cold this
winter we need to help people see some
of the most vulnerable people in our
society what liberal democrats are
saying we need to be able to take money
straight off their heating bills
and we want to extend the support
schemes to millions more people
to help pensioners to help people on low
incomes working families on low incomes
with children and if we help those
people who are really struggling at the
moment i think it is reasonable to ask
those firms who are making unexpectedly
high profits to contribute
i mean fairness is a nice idea isn't it
but we the world isn't fair is it uh and
this is a short-term fix if you were
able to tax these companies it would
just be a one-off
well we only want a one-off tax actually
we want uh the help to be this year
hopefully gas prices and therefore
heating bills will fall next year and
the long-term solution is to insulate
people's homes more and to remove the
amount of gas we need by going into
renewables liberal democrats when i was
energy secretary did just that we
quadrupled renewable power so we didn't
need so much gas we made britain the
world leading offshore wind very proud
of that liberal democrat record
unfortunately the conservatives haven't
taken that on moreover we um put energy
efficiency and insulation into
many many people's homes over a million
homes we insulated so they need less gas
to heat them so their bills are
protected unfortunately under
conservatives those sorts of policies
were absolutely reduced or ended
entirely there is no proper home
insulation program for anyone at the
moment in the uk that is a very bad
thing for the long-term
energy security of our country it's bad
for climate change and it's really bad
for bill payers so liberal democrats
have a short-term solution uh where
we're going to increase things like the
warm home discount the pensioners winter
fuel allowance paid for by these oil and
gas companies that's a good solution now
to help people now but we have solutions
for the next year for the years ahead
which will mean that we won't be in this
situation in the future i'm really uh
really quite angry actually on behalf of
millions of people the conservatives
have let us down with some really bad
energy policies
a lot of people will look at your ideas
about renewable energy and will say you
know that's something we can we can
support we think it's a good idea to not
use the earth's resources but
equally using fully renewable energy in
the future doesn't mean that our energy
prices are going to go down does it it
is it is things like insulation that
will make the difference we're not all
suddenly going to see reduced bills if
we get all our power from from wind and
wave are we
well you're right that energy insulation
home insulation is the best way because
then you're not using energy in the
first place that's why liberal democrats
have championed home insulation energy
efficiency and the conservatives have
been had a dreadful record on it but
actually
renewable energy is now the cheapest
energy thanks to the policies that
liberal democrats introduced the price
of renewable energy has tumbled and so
in the future renewable power will be
much cheaper than fossil fuel power and
moreover we don't have to import it so i
don't see why the government aren't
doing far far more to invest in the
offshore industry but also the solar and
tidal industry this will make britain
far more independent far more secure it
will help people with their bills and it
will help climate change the
government's failure to go further and
faster on renewables building on the
work that liberal democrats did is a
real real uh betrayal of our country and
i say that in in in strong terms
this this this prime minister in
particular has failed our country on
energy policies and that's why people
are ending up with such high high
heating bills
while we have you here um the
government's announced changes uh
encoded restrictions for travel from
friday and also uh reductions in pcr
testing are those both changes that the
lib dems welcome
they look the right things and what i'd
like to see from this government on not
just these changes but all changes is
far more transparency with the advice
from the scientists and the experts
the problem with boris johnson
over kovid is he hasn't taken advice of
some of the experts we find afterwards
and moreover because he hasn't obeyed
the rules that he's required everyone
else to obey
there's a lot of people who don't trust
him anymore and we in a public health
crisis we need the government to be
trusted and this prime minister has
undermined people's trust in what the
government say so i i think it's
absolutely essential as we go forward
and tackle this appalling pandemic and
protect people
we have much more transparency on what
the experts are actually saying and that
way we might be able to restore some
trust and therefore tackle this pandemic
far more effectively
okay and while we have you finally is a
is lindsay hoyle off your christmas card
list for next year after he got your
name wrong yesterday and called you had
bought
not at all not at all uh it's an easy
mistake to make and uh his offices
apologize so i i take that in very good
spirit
there are so many ads but uh it's good
to have you on davey thanks very
much thank you
let's get a look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it'll turn wet and windy from the west
today with snow on the hills
britain mostly dry and calm with an
extensive frost severe in some places
ireland and northern ireland will see
any frost soon lifting as wind and rain
spread from the west
northern and western britain will turn
wet and windy this morning with coastal
gales there'll be snow on the hills and
to low levels in the north for a time
elsewhere eastern england will stay fine
while ireland and northern ireland will
see rain giving way to blustery wintry
showers some of those heavy and thundery
it'll be cold in the east milder
elsewhere rain and hill snow will clear
into the east later
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
coming up we'll have the latest as novak
djokovic appeals against the
cancellation of his visa ahead of this
month's australian open there's a
hearing currently happening in australia
if we get any decision from it we will
bring it to you here on skyny's
breakfast
[Music]
you